hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today we're going to focus on the
features of the Persian language around
three years ago I made a video about
Persian and that was actually the very
first language profile video on this
channel but that video focused mainly on
the history of the language so I wanted
to add another video focusing on its
features so let's get right into it
Persian is a plural centric language
with three different standard varieties
the standard Persian of Iran standard
dari in Afghanistan and standard Tajik
of Tajikistan and also whose Becca Stan
were ATS a minority language and of
course each country where at spoken has
various spoken dialects along with the
Persian of Iran dari and Tajik are also
commonly referred to as Farsi by many
speakers which means Persian the focal
point for this video will be the Persian
language of Iran and when dealing with
the colloquial language specifically the
dialect of Tehran the Tajik variety of
Persian is written in a modified form of
the Cyrillic alphabet while dari and the
standard variety of Iran are written in
a modified form of the Arabic script
people who don't know the Arabic script
or any of its derivatives may take one
look at Persian and assume that it's a
highly inaccessible language but the
script is actually not very hard to
learn it's based on the 28 characters of
the Arabic script but it adds four
additional characters in order to make
consonant distinctions that don't occur
in Arabic it's an abjad rather than an
alphabet so as in Arabic short vowels
are generally not indicated in writing
only long vowels and this is probably
the hardest thing about it for example
this is the word for I cherish here we
have three letters showing consonants
sure sure look and that's it but we can
write the short vowel with a diacritic
like this and just as a quick side note
in colloquial speech this word might be
pronounced Tisch some words undergo
contractions in colloquial speech words
often contain a combination of short and
long vowels so some vowels might be
indicated in writing while others aren't
like in this word for train kata the
first vowel is short and written with a
diacritic while the second one is long
and written with a letter the diacritics
for short
owls are normally only written for
children's and beginners material but
once you know a word you don't need the
diacritics to read it and don't let the
script distract you from the fact that
persian is an indo-european language so
it's related to most of the languages of
Europe including the romance Germanic
and Slavic languages as well as the
indo-european languages of the Indian
subcontinent like Hindi and Urdu if you
speak one of those languages some
elements of Persian might seem quite
familiar to you indo-european vocabulary
you'll likely notice a significant
amount of cognate vocabulary between
Persian and other indo-european
languages depending on which ones you
know of course a lot of these words are
very basic ones ma dad meaning mother
had an father matter dad brother da
daughter that door then done tooth
related to the word dental or don't in
French Nam name gov cow
moosh Mouse shesh sheesh six paddy fairy
Tom dad Thunder so tune pillar or column
but cognate with stone
Todd each dork yeah warm no new chair
like okay in Italian or okay in Spanish
okay that like cook in French or que in
Spanish he means who like key in Italian
or key in French and some verbs to more
than meaning to die related to French
Mulia
Spanish Maria and English mortal and
murder wrong then to drive but cognate
with English run ro guden cognate with
English Rob asked is also a in French
and s in Spanish not all Persian
vocabulary as indo-european there's also
a significant amount of Arabic
vocabulary that was adopted into Persian
moreso in literature than in everyday
speech a few examples the greeting Salam
comes from the Arabic word Salam meaning
peace the word for thank you
the Shaq kiram comes from the Arabic
word meaning thankful with the shockula
with the person conjugation meaning I am
jadeed meaning knew a moment ago we saw
the indo-european word no meaning new
this is an alternate word many Arabic
borrowings also have native Persian
equivalents that's meaning lesson or
course from the Arabic noun meaning
lesson there are many Arabic words in
Persian but the percentage of Arabic
words depends on the formality and style
of speech or writing pronunciation the
pronunciation of Persian is not too
complicated
most of the consonant sounds are sounds
that appear in English but the following
consonants are worth noting huh
this is like the consonant at the end of
Scottish law Northcote an O in Iranian
Persian today these are both mainly the
same sound which is a voiced equivalent
of a a consonant which exists in Arabic
oh yeah um traditionally these were
different sounds and then that was
pronounced ha but the two sounds have
mostly merged this is like the French je
sound yeah it mainly appears in
loanwords you on ha the Persian Rohtak
sound is normally an alveolar tap more
than it also appears as a short alveolar
trill though that seems inconsistent and
depends on the speaker tongue dad there
are six basic vowel sounds 3 short and 3
long short ah
Oh long e the long vowels are pronounced
longer and are represented by abjad
characters in writing and as I mentioned
before the short vowels are only
indicated with diacritics which are not
normally written notice that the to a
sounds are not only different in length
but also quality the long vowel is more
of an open back vowel ah while the short
version is an open front vowel ah stress
usually occurs on the last syllable of
words then done but this is not always
the case with verbs because the stress
moves depending on the presence of
certain particles or affixes
grammar in many ways Persian grammar is
simple and straightforward
there is no grammatical gender there are
no definite articles this is the word
for book kitab by itself it's definite
this means the book if we want to make
it indefinite we add an indefinite
article yet Kitab
to me this is pretty cool because it's
usually the opposite some languages have
no indefinite article only a definite
article the indefinite article is
actually the number one but it's
commonly used like an indefinite article
there's also another way of making a
noun indefinite with an indefinite
suffix e kitabi what if we want to add
an adjective to a noun adjectives work
quite simply they come after the noun
and a particle F is inserted between the
noun and the adjective the new book
catawba jadeed a new book yet catawba
jadeed note that after a vowel the
particle f becomes yeah if we add an
adjective to the other indefinite form
kitabi then there is no particle yet
between the words the indefinite suffix
e seems to override the particle yeah if
they are both supposed to appear in the
same position but the indefinite suffix
is actually a clinic so that it can be
freely placed after either the noun or
the adjective if it's after the
adjective then the particle at does
appear catawba jdd this particle that
connects a noun to an adjective is
called is a faith now what if we want to
say this in the plural the plural is
formed with the suffix ha or aw in
colloquial Persian the new books kitab
hyatt are they
note that adjectives don't have any
special plural form if I've been
explaining this well then hopefully
you've gotten the sense that Persian is
not such a complicated language there
are noun cases but don't worry in
Persian they're actually quite
straightforward there are five noun
cases four of which are indicated by
adding a preposition before the noun or
a post position after the nel nominative
this case uses the basic noun on its own
the book is good j-dog fauvist
kitab is the subject here accusative i
read the book
man Katara condom Kitab is the direct
object meaning it receives the action so
it's followed by the accusative marker
law dative this case shows that the noun
receives an action often with a
component of movement or direction I
looked at the book man- Nagar jardim the
preposition that precedes kitab to show
the dative locative this case indicates
where an action takes place I wrote in
the book man that gets a knavish them
notice the preposition
daaad before kitab ablative this case
indicates the origin or place where an
action comes from I learned from the
book man has kitab-o-moosa noticed the
preposition as before kitab i should
point out that the word almost um is
used in writing but not so often in
speech in speech it's more common to say
yuck yet if thumb man as kitab yot yet
if thumb word order let's take one of
the sentences we just looked at the one
with the accusative case and examine its
word order man Katara son damn I read
the book word-for-word its eye book
accusative marker read the basic order
in Persian is sov with the verb at the
end but subject pronouns can normally be
dropped because the conjugation of the
verb makes the person and number of the
subject clear now let's add an adjective
to that sentence catawba toes it a
condom this now means I read the new
book so again the subject pronoun isn't
needed so this is object verb but if the
subject is a specific person then of
course you need to include it so let's
add a name dorosch Kotova tow0 haand
Darius read the new book so now it's
back to sov notice that when we add an
adjective to describe the noun the
accusative marker law comes after the
adjective in other words it comes after
the whole noun phrase and remember the
particle at which comes between the noun
and the adjective that follows a change
also took place in the conjugation of
the verb when we added the name Darius
because we changed the sentence from
first person singular to third-person
singular but will
look at verbs a little later what if we
add an adverb to this sentence the
placement of the adverb is flexible but
it normally won't come last because the
verb comes last now let's add the word
study which means quickly the huge sette
cataratas era fund this now means darius
quickly read the new book so the adverb
can go here before the object or it can
go after the object and before the verb
the huge guitar Bertos era sati hunt or
it can go at the beginning before the
subject though that's less common sati
DeRusha guitar because it are fond let's
go back to the first version of this
sentence now we know that darius is the
subject so let's change that to a
pronoun ooh before we saw the first
person subject pronoun men and now this
is the third person singular for human
subjects for non-human subjects there's
another pronoun on remember that these
subject pronouns are optional now let's
replace the object with an object
pronoun you can simply use the subject
pronoun and together with the accusative
marker at all it functions as the object
pronoun Oh sati Andra Hans he quickly
read it there are also separate object
pronoun suffixes which can be used
instead of the subject pronouns they are
attached to the ends of verbs Oh sati
fun - these suffixes are not only the
object pronoun suffixes but also
possessive suffixes he quickly read his
book you said he gets all by straw fund
here the suffix attaches to the noun and
means his and could mean her or it's in
a different sentence verbs verbs in
Persian generally follow regular
intuitive patterns there are some
compound tenses they get a little more
complex but the more basic ones are
quite straightforward
verbs have two stems a past tense stem
and the present tense stem and these
form the basis of most of the verb
tenses let's use the example of the verb
meaning to eat for then this is the
infinitive by removing on from the
infinitive we get the past tense stem or
by removing dawn from the infinitive we
get the present tense stem or I should
note that the present tense stems of
verbs
not usually this predictable and
generally need to be memorized to the
stem you add a personal ending that
clearly identifies the person and number
of the subject let's use the first
person plural jaurim then we add
something before the verb to indicate
the aspect of present tense for general
or habitual present tense you add me me
her team we eat if it's present
progressive you add the present tense of
the verb
gosh tan to have dharam me 14 we are
eating this present progressive form is
not used in formal or literary Persian
only colloquial Persian the general
present can also be used to express
present progressive to form the simple
past we add the personal ending to the
past stem for the hordeum we ate another
past form is the imperfect which is used
to express the past habitual like used
to or the past progressive like I was
doing you simply add the particle me
before the simple past form meal or
theme we were eating or we used to eat
like in the present tense there's an
additional form in colloquial speech
that strengthens the past progressive
aspect you add - done to have before me
- team me or Dean there's also a future
tense which is formed with the present
tense of a verb
Costin meaning want followed by the past
tense stem of the main verb haha and
Hort they will eat but this future tense
is often not used in colloquial speech
because the present tense can be used
with future meaning there's also a
simple perfect for present perfect tense
to form this you use the perfect
participle form which is the past stem
plus a and follow it with an abbreviated
form of the present tense of the verb to
be
for the end they have eaten and is the
third-person plural form and if we
change that to the past tense of the
verb to be we get the pluperfect or past
perfect tense horrid Abood and they had
eaten there are other compound tenses as
well but the ones we've covered so far
should give you a general idea of how
the verb tenses work questions now if
you want to turn that sentence into a
question what
you do well you can simply use rising
intonation [ __ ] Abood and in literary
Persian you can add the yes/no question
marker oh yeah at the beginning of the
sentence are your dividend but what
about open-ended questions here are the
basic question words T who chair
what koja where K when Shara why cheat
or how padam which the question word
usually comes after the subject if the
subject is included in the sentence to
Jimmy Chloe what are you eating
word for word it you want to eat or in
the colloquial present progressive form
Tochigi me Chloe
how are you Harley Shamar chat or asked
here
Holly shoma is the subject which means
your condition then chat or meaning how
comes after the subject and the
third-person singular present tense of
the verb meaning to be comes at the end
so word for word it your condition how
is one important thing to notice in this
sentence here is that this phrase shows
another use of Azoff a using the
particle F to connect to words when we
saw it before it connected a noun and an
adjective but this time it connects a
noun to a pronoun to show possession is
off a can also be used to connect two
nouns with the second one adding meaning
to the first one it's other that's
meaning textbook the first word Kitab
means book as you know and the second
dass means lesson or course literally
you could translate it as lesson book or
course book now that we've examined some
of the key features of persian let's
look at one more sentence and see what
we find
this sentence means the children like
bread but they don't like vegetables but
Jehan and reduced or and very sad the
dirt reduce nagar and word for word its
children bred accusative marker they
like but vegetables accusative marker
they don't like first we have the word
for children but chi ha the singular is
bad cheer and as we saw before you add
ha to form the plural
next is the word for bread nun or noon
in informal speech and it's followed by
the accusative marker at the end of this
clause we have the verb as usual but
this verb is a little different than the
ones we saw before this is a compound
verb which is made up of two words
deuced
a noun meaning friend and - Dan the verb
meaning to have here conjugated for the
third person plural yes the verb for
like in Persian literally means have
friend if you examine its parts many
many verbs in Persian are compound verbs
like this which are made up of a verb
and another element like a noun or
adjective a few more examples sad is
that an head plus hit means to pay a
visit for sure then leg plus become
means to stand up then the e car then
life plus do means to live the most
common verb used to form compound verbs
is cat then compound verbs account for
most of the verbs used in Persian only
around a hundred simple verbs are used
on a regular basis and the rest are
compound verbs now back to the sentence
here we see the conjunction valley
meaning but next we see the plural noun
meaning vegetables sabzi chart the
singular form is sabzi so the regular
plural form is sabzi ha but when
referring to vegetables in general the
common word is sabzi chart which means
vegetables and herbs then next we see
the accusative marker again and then we
see the negative form of the compound
verb we saw a moment ago news Nagaland
to make a verb negative you just add nan
before the conjugated verb as you can
see Persian is quite a straightforward
language which might come as a surprise
to some of you who were initially scared
off by the script aside from the verbs
everything seems to follow regular
patterns without many exceptions and
even the verbs while there are some
complex and irregular forms work quite
logically this makes Persian seem like
quite a fun language to learn one of the
challenges is probably the difference
between the spoken colloquial language
and the written formal language because
the written formal language hasn't
really changed in hundreds of years but
it seems that most learners of Persian
get used to these differences without
too much trouble
the question of the day for native
speakers and fluent second language
speakers of Persian what other features
of Persian do you think are important or
valuable for us to know about and for
learners of Persian what's been your
experience with studying Persian what
have you found challenging and what have
you found enjoyable be sure to follow
Lange focus on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram and once again thank you to my
wonderful patreon supporters especially
these ones right here on the screen who
are my top tier patreon supporters many
special thanks to them and to everyone
thank you for watching and have a nice
day
[Music]